we begin this morning with a major staff
shake-up at the White House Reince
Priebus is out as president Trump's
chief of staff after six months of
infighting chaos and little progress in
advancing president Trump's legislative
agenda Priebus will be replaced by the
current Homeland Security Secretary
General John Kelly Friday's move comes
less than a day after president Trump's
push to repeal Obamacare failed in the
Senate and the publication of a New
Yorker article in which the new White
House communications chief Anthony
scaramouche II warned that previous days
in the administration were numbered
Errol Barnett is in our Washington
bureau Erol good morning good morning
president Trump has reshuffled his staff
once again kicking out longtime ally
Wright's Priebus with Republican
National Committee alum Sean Spicer also
on his way out soon Homeland Security
Secretary General John Kelly replaces
Priebus but it remains to be seen if
this action will get the White House
back on track returning from delivering
a speech on immigration on a rainy
Friday in Washington President Donald
Trump confirmed what he had just tweeted
that the White House chief of staff
Reince Priebus was out and Secretary
Kelly was in
[Music]
John Kelly will do a fantastic job
General Kelly has been a star done an
incredible job thus far respected by
everybody a great great American Reince
Priebus a good man
his praise comes after a public power
struggle between Priebus and the newly
appointed White House communications
director Anthony scaramouche II earlier
this week scaramouche II was quoted in
The New Yorker calling Priebus a
paranoid schizophrenic this is I think
good for the president Priebus the
former chairman of the Republican
National Committee has long clashed with
Washington Outsiders within the
administration and reportedly blocked
Skaar Moochie from joining the White
House during the transition but on CNN
Friday Priebus had only positive things
to say about his exit I will be working
on a transition here for a couple of
weeks together with general Kelly
starting on Monday morning so this isn't
a this isn't that like a situation where
there's a bunch of ill-will feelings
this latest change follows a major blow
to president Trump's top campaign
promise to repeal and replace Obamacare
this is a disappointment Republican
senators Lisa Murkowski Susan Collins
and John McCain voted down the so called
skinny repeals
the moment when Senator McCain placed
his thumbs down vote produced gasps in
the Senate chamber
President Trump accused the three
Republicans and 48 Democrats of letting
the country down you can't have
everything boy oh boy they've been
working on that one for seven years can
you believe that
now Congress did pass a sanctions bill
against Russia for its election
interference with North Korea and Iran
attached to it and it has enough support
to override a presidential veto
well after initially sending mixed
signals the White House now says
president Trump approves of the bill and
intends to sign it Anthony
Errol Barnett in our Washington bureau
Thank You Errol